preliminaries and david anton will have
the white pieces here we go
yeah i was just looking as well we could
end up in a situation with four or five
players on 22 points and it's just about
their head-to-head scores so
head-to-head is important that's why
this game both players will want to win
despite the fact they're on level points
despite the fact they're just inside top
eight and okay a quiet start to this
game it's a queen's pawn opening not the
london system not the queen's gambit
just david anton there just pushing upon
building a solid wall of pawns so
maybe his strategy david anton is to
just survive the opening keep an eye on
the other results and then decide what
to do and prague copies it
he copies the setup it's complete
symmetry so far white's bishop now
developing white ready to castle the
king already
at this early stage and yeah the cagey
start prague what's he going to do he
looks full of energy rocking back and
forth i mean it must be early hours of
the morning though already right yeah
3am and uh yeah he's clearly full of and
he must be high on adrenaline after that
incredible game yeah i mean absolutely i
mean especially because jordan perhaps
wasn't someone that he'd
had pegged down that he was going to
beat and now he's realizing that if he
manages to secure
a point at least
that he could qualify for the
quarterfinals and that that would be
a dream come true oh absolutely
and the only thing is that it can be a
card occasionally to come back down to
earth just kind of play with a stable
mindset after such an amazing victory
like his last game sometimes you're
still carried away sometimes you just
think okay luck's on my side you get a
bit too artistic a bit too complacent
and
chess things can backfire you've got to
be objective still so prague in a way he
needs to just forget the last game and
just think okay it's all about this one
shot this one penalty kick and there's
one opportunity and
if the chance comes to play for a win
try and seize it if it's just level
playing for a draw maybe that's a decent
result too he's still got good odds to
qualify but uh yeah so far he's playing
very sensibly as black still a very
standard position
uh i think they call this the collie
collie system i was going to ask you the
name yeah i think it's the collie right
because i always get them confused
torrey and the colleague tori is when
you bring the bishop out collie is when
you lock the bishop in yeah so yeah this
this opening i must admit when i was
young it was the bane of my life
everyone played this against me when i
had black i didn't know what to do white
system it might look innocuous it might
look really innocent and
kind of
unimpressive but there are ideas and
we'll talk about these ideas as this
opening progresses white is the first to
castle black now ready to do the same
and
then our good friend simon williams with
a very nice game
the british with this particular
variation is white so it looks like it's
a very quiet line you know
quite systematic playing
moves by hand you know not without not
too much thought
but it does have some venom yeah against
ravi harrier 2019 that's right yeah and
uh yeah the whole reason white goes for
this setup is because actually that dark
square bishop white's bishop of the b2
square is on a nice diagonal and that
diagonal is likely to open up at some
point at the very least with white you
can hop into the center to the e5 square
with the white knight and
yeah some very kind of specific ideas it
tends to be just pattern recognition
here black tries to cut across those
ideas of course later on but uh yeah we
talk about the 1b3 opening as well and
white's basically done that but a
different version of it white's bishop
that dark square bishop look out for it
it might be the decider it might be the
key piece later on i'm just loving
fiance bishops in general and uh pragma
does castle he's got a healthy set up as
well with black he occupies the center
with some pawns he still has to answer
the question of that black light squared
bishop but once he does that he's got a
healthy uh playable position at least
surprisingly evaluation possible white's
favor because it looks sensible
yeah i mean this is still very much
mainline theory so
okay and the pawn just steps forward
again very normal very thematic stopping
the black knight from jumping in to the
white half and there we go black is
playing copycat doing the same with his
light squad bishop that white has done
with his dark square bishop and uh young
christophe duda and dingleran have
played a draw to
secure their spots in the quantum finals
well most likely but
i would say they have secured their spot
they're both now on 23 points after that
draw
a sensible time to take a quick draw
mm-hmm and maybe is that the first quick
draw we've seen them
yeah i think it is yes but it's going to
impact their fighting chest all day
we did see that magnus and ding were
tormented by the quick draw because you
know
the algorithm punishes you it does
punish you
and uh anyhow there's a decision to be
made on the board for pragnanda which
way should he recapture that form with
the bishop with the pawn both sides have
their prose and they also have their
disadvantages whilst we're waiting for a
decision to be made
well
we have some selfies i wanted to show
you the first one comes from flowy who's
also feeling unwell they got tested
positive for covid only a few hours ago
thanks for keeping me company during
isolation
oh
sorry to hear that flowey i do hope that
it's a relatively you know it's one of
those covert situations we don't suffer
yeah and that you get uh well very soon
but um if you are in isolation for a few
days well
the chess keeps going all the way until
saturday tomorrow is the quarter finals
we then have semi-finals and then a
two-day final
to finish this off and find out who the
winner is yeah
okay and prague chooses to capture
towards the center with a pawn you
mentioned pros and cons of anchor and uh
that was very much the case and uh okay
the one con to capturing back with uh
with your pawn towards the center is
that now black's pawns are getting
undermined by the white pawns if you
captured back with the bishop earlier
you can play with pieces now you're
reliant on playing with pawns so
pregnant are choosing the most ambitious
option but maybe the least solid option
so now it's very clear what david anton
wants to do he wants to fight against
these black pawns
in the center
so prague needs to develop his pieces he
wants to be ready for when some pressure
really does arise
against his pawns
and who do you prefer here i know it's
early stages
i
generally prefer white's flexibility but
i can see
why maybe some players would like having
these extra central pawns in the middle
of the board yeah i'm one of these
players who like having their central
pawns uh
i just the way that i handle them is i
basically don't take a decision with
them as much for as long as possible i
just sit there and enjoy the space as
for as long as i can so i would just
develop all my pieces you know connect
the rooks and then i wait and i wait and
i wait and i find that people can't
handle that waiting too long and they
make mistakes
because
it's human it's human to get impatient
and actually want to take action to do
something and i do the same ivanka just
on the other side i like to play against
these pawns and just wait and wait and
wait until they become weaknesses or
commit
and then leave weak squares behind and
meanwhile a non-committal move from
pregnant in terms of his pieces and his
pawns in the center but he just improves
his rook look at that black rook that's
just moved it's eyeing up this white
dark square bishop i already highlighted
that as the potentially key piece and
he's just putting pressure on the pawn
in front of it on the b3 square and the
piece behind so really nice move that
from pregnant just we saw in the last
game if his pieces have energy he tends
to be happy and that black rook very
very happy where it is right now and uh
yeah david anton meanwhile we've seen a
lot of decisive results from him i
wouldn't be surprised if he's very high
up on the fighting chess index
uh after this tournament
just a very entertaining player a very
creative player i've found i've played
him many times and my results have been
good but i don't think i've ever
predicted more than one or two of his
moves in a row
just every turn he surprises me
he's got a very unorthodox way of
thinking about the game of setting
problems he's very tricky as well
calculates well
but uh sometimes if you play classically
against him just trying to blunt his
creativity
he gets frustrated there so okay a
semi threat on the board maybe white
look how the bishops are both pointing
towards the black king and the white
queen there teaming up with her bishop
to on this diagonal and pregnant blocks
things up
quick capture
in the center we talked about pawns and
not committing them she's made that
commitment ivanka
yeah what do you think of this one
i i
don't like it
for white or white okay
i
i mean
there was no need there were pieces to
be developed so there were rooks to join
in the game there was no need to rush
for something like this
okay so uh we should jump in to show why
black isn't losing a pawn here maybe
because actually it looks like black has
just thrown a ball away this square
white is a pawn up it's defended twice
by a knight and bishop and it's only
attacked twice as well by black's pieces
but look at this pregnant
jumping in with his knight and now if
knight takes knight pawn recaptures if
uh david anton gets greedy here and
captures in the center we see an
indirect attack
by the black queen and he plays bishop
takes pawn check throwing his bishop
away but winning the black bishop and
suddenly attack on the rook also the
king very vulnerable but look at this
surprising decision by david anton but
maybe quite a strong one instead of
taking with his knight he's captured
with his bishop instead and uh after
this trade he's just gonna rely on these
pawns running forward it's all about
flank pawns here the b and c pawns
against the central pawns and uh i don't
know personally i prefer the central
pawns but
it takes a while for them to get
motoring
and okay this one it's anything but safe
chest from both sides is anything but a
draw for example if we do see white
stepping forward with the pawn black
doing the same
i mean i have no idea whose pawn chain
is stronger these three connected or
these two in the center there's more at
stake for the white side maybe because
the central pawns look super scary but
you can block them you can stop their
advance the knight covers the square the
bishop ii and the queen as well and no
more
advance no more adventure for this pawn
in the middle
yeah and in light of that i was thinking
maybe
pragananda has actually made a mistake
by retreating his
his bishop on that square because i mean
yeah
yeah it's tricky is there's a really
complicated position i mean i mean white
has all the long-term trumps because
those uh past pawns that he has on the
left on the left side they can be
incredibly powerful difficult to stop
whilst
i don't know it's it's it's it's very
tense it's a really i guess you're
hesitating because it's just so hard to
evaluate and the players i don't think
they'll be sure how to evaluate either
at least black can maybe do some knight
jumping you can jump towards the uh
towards the white king
yeah it's just really really unclear uh
black has the bishop pair but it's maybe
less of a factor than the current pawn
structure white with these strong pawns
of course and black with these guys
it's uh yeah definitely warming up this
battle and uh let's go back to the
players
i just like the fact that they are both
taking risks and playing
for the maximum on every turn and david
anton another thing i mentioned about
him or that i want to mention is that he
loves his imbalances
and there we go he moves his rook across
instead of throwing the white pawns
forward first he wants to prevent or at
least delay the advance of black's pawns
in the center and uh there we go just
hydrating very sensible in a high stress
situation yeah
yeah and i'm guessing that pregnancy
probably will copy as well you know
white says no you can't advance you're
born and he will say yes let me do it
and
let me try to get that pawn pushed at
least move the black rook one square
across to the center and i'm i'm sitting
here chatting to thai
to just you know get updated on these uh
you know stats for who's gonna make it
through so the draw between duda and
ding it did secure duda's spot in the
quarter finals and it's actually good
news for these two
so that draw if this game is now a draw
then both of these players will have an
89 percent chance to go through
uh it's going to be
a draw here will then be bad news for um
for vedic it's going to mean
he's probably out
but i don't think these players will be
aware i mean they can see the results
from other games but if they're aware
that now a draw
gives them very big chances to qualify i
don't know if they're aware of that
maybe they need tie on speed dial just
to find out the stats but yeah on a
serious note though i mean
psychologically it's so hard i've been
in these situations myself and
do you even want to know the other
results do you focus on the board and
just try and play the best moves and
take things as they come because if
you're thinking too much about the
results if you're thinking oh a draw
might give me an 80 90 chance of
qualifying you might take a passive
option playing for the draw is actually
the worst way to get it you should just
play good moves play for the win and at
some point you'll get to repeat the
position or you'll get to sacrifice
something and just kind of swap off all
the material
so yeah sometimes
kind of thinking too much about the
result can backfire all of my most
heartbreaking defeats have been because
i was thinking about the result too much
yeah i have to say whenever i've been in
this particular situation i found that
the best approach is just to focus on my
game forget the others you have no
control on what other people do the only
thing you can control is well how many
good moves you make and you can only do
that if you're fully focused on the game
i can relate from playing golf so it's a
it's always a goal in golf to lower your
handicap so to always play a better
round than the previous round and as
soon as i see oh i have a lot of points
now if i play this next shot really
nicely i can lower my handicap and then
it's out in the woods every single time
yep yeah i mean these two players credit
to them they look super focused i doubt
that they've got
kind of other screens up just kind of
looking at those other games looking at
the other results which they're allowed
to do it looks like they're very much
focused on this position specifically
and as expected white has built this
nice pawn chain on the left side black
in the center also trying to mobilize
and
this also looks like the type of
position you've anchor i don't know if
you agree but the evaluation bar it
might swing side to side
it's just
really it's just unbalanced
uncompromising because the pawn
structure is so weird because the piece
uh kind of complic combination as well
it's just
slightly unorthodox with the black
bishops but then they're feeling a bit
uh kind of they're feeling like
bystanders right now yeah especially the
dark squared bishop you know it's just
jammed in by its own porn and also
white's lovely pawn chain is uh
controlling a lot of nice squares and
it's it's not entirely clear what the
plan is
i mean
i mean yeah you know white will of
course like mobilize the nights and then
there will be and
then and they're saying gays for black
you know yes
develop the light square bishop
but what next
not easy and i think you just have to
almost take this position on a move by
move basis yep agreed fully agreed and
it will come down to kind of a boiling
point later where it's purely about
calculation and who can push their pawns
forward successfully and whether you can
prevent your opponent's pawns marching
forward successfully but right now is
kind of the calm before the storm where
it's still slightly cagey black there
just pushing a pawn covering some
squares giving the black king some
breathing space getting that pawn off
the diagonal of the white bishop and
queen white meanwhile maybe gonna try
and improve the rooks and prove the
knights as ivanka mentioned
it's going to just enter a kind of a
mini maneuvering phase and then it will
explode and then we'll see those pawn
pushes and then we'll see some real
chaos and uh yeah still
if i had to predict i think a draw
extremely unlikely in this one even if
it helps both players understandings
all right well it's so typical in this
round 15 that the games are just sort of
waiting for each other to see what's
happening in the others the bars have
been slightly to the middle but
in the game between liam lee and richard
report the bar has slightly gone to
richard report side he's uh fighting for
a win to qualify
and if he wins that game well it could
mean magnus carlsen with a win against
beat it could clinch the number one spot
but that's going to go down to the sun
and burger the tie break thing you know
it would be impossible to calculate for
us where's my glittery calculator oh we
forgot it this time oh yeah we need to
get that back we'll have to rely on ty
to let us know keep us informed on stats
like that but yeah i mean head to head
is hard to calculate especially if
there's more than two players on the
same score
um
number of wins we can count but the
players they won't necessarily know
their opponent's results
yeah it's really complex that's why it's
just better to focus on the game and
uh yeah we get access of course to the
evaluation bars and despite the fact the
other players can check in on the other
games they won't have that ability so
they won't know how the other games are
going
it's
definitely a distraction to look over at
another game try to evaluate it try to
work out what's going on
and uh okay meanwhile nice move from
david anton just sliding the white rock
across he's hinting that maybe he's
relying on the white sea pawn the most
far advanced pawn for him to do the
damage later to push that guy forward
yeah but then again the white queen
maybe needs to reroute itself getting in
the way of her rook
and okay prague uh just bringing his
knight to the center another idea we
discussed briefly
and uh maybe as well as jumping into the
f4 square where black knights are really
dangerous the white king will start to
sweat uh also the black queen has opened
up a diagonal maybe it wants to use that
one yeah a bit later on
no i was just smiling because you use
the word distraction and that's like a
nice link into
my the next selfie that i'd love to show
you
female nurse says that they're trying
their best to read even just one page
but i can't resist watching you guys
sorry for being a distraction female
nurse and i hope you're able to
multitask and enjoy the chess commentary
and also read a book yeah maybe studying
yeah
i don't think we should get blamed it's
the players it's their fault they keep
playing exciting games they're i mean
the standings are so so close so tight
no i can take the blame
i'll be happy to be somewhat someone's
distraction that's what i was going to
say but that sounded a bit strange
all right well these two are in deep
thought clocks ticking for dave danton
going down to uh nine minutes on the
clock and we're not we don't know if
these people these two players are aware
that a draw is good news and
is
going to probably clinch them a spot in
the knockout stage
does it seem like on their play that
they're just going for the win both of
them yes
the drawers are far from both players
minds maybe they just thought okay
winning this game will guarantee it yeah
that's true so why not go for the win
even prague with black we've seen him
beat magnus carlsen with black in the
past he doesn't really care white black
it doesn't matter when he's uh well it
doesn't matter to the young indian
wonderking so and uh just according to
um tai it's amazing to just be able to
sit here and talk to him
um
has a much better
son burger the tie breaks than magnus so
he's definitely going to be the winner
of the preliminaries impressive by liam
lee
there is no way magnus can catch up with
him even with a win they will be on the
same score but liam liam has better tie
breaks yeah and it's a serious advantage
actually
to be a top of the table oh yeah we've
seen it yeah we have seen it before but
at first you know you're thinking now
it's not a big deal but i mean the
ability to choose colours when you're
playing the match and when you're
playing tie breaks i mean we've seen it
been super instrumental especially if it
came down to armageddon
where one player was able to say hey i'm
going to choose white i'm going to have
that extra time and i'm just going to
win the game on the basis of that
and on paper i guess you have a slightly
easier route to the final maybe if it's
according to ratings according to the
tour well according to the top eight
standings
um and yeah liam deserves that because
holding that game earlier that we saw
against magnus i mean that was just one
of some of the most tenacious defense
we've seen in the tournament so uh yeah
well played to liam for winning the
prelims
but yeah back to this game and
david anton spending significant amount
of time i think on this move and he's
right to do so because it's a critical
moment and black's knight if it jumps in
i mean it has eyes on both sides of the
board but if it jumps in then white has
some serious questions to answer
so big moment now for david anton yeah
and earlier i thought it was easier for
white to play maybe just for this move
at least it's not that case it's really
tricky to find a move
and uh he does make a move improving his
night
and
i just
you have to bear with me i also want to
show another warning that mariana
lopez's cat has for david anton
pragananda too much thinking makes you
go sleepy makes her cat go sleepy
i know the feeling
we're going to sleep many times at the
dress board yeah well we do know uh
vedic sitting in india same as pregnant
it's super late for them veda did tell
us that he did have a nap in his chair
during one of these days in the
preliminaries
yeah it's better snap between the rounds
at least than during the rounds very
true and uh two players that are
definitely not napping are these two
because things are indeed as predicted
heating up and there are tactics all
over the place now it looks like black
is giving up a pawn but he's actually
going for a checkmating attack against
the white king and the checkmating
attack has been signaled by the advance
of this knight with white we say the
knight on f5 will thrive and f4 is the
kind of counterpart square to that so
the black knight now pointing towards
this white king and if white gets greedy
which he might do because i'm struggling
to see what else but if he jumps forward
and takes this pawn it looks like a free
pawn after a capture uh maybe after the
night takes black is going to try and
bring his queen out so it's a double
attack and okay we haven't seen this but
he's threatening checkmate on this
square using the queen and knight but
he's also hitting the white knight in
the middle of the board with his rook
and with his queen and a tricky move
from david anton instead this looks a
bit scary for white so he avoided this
he gave a check and now the question is
which way to go do you go to the safer
corner
or do you go towards the center of the
board center of the board
looks a bit scary because you're out in
the open and later on there might be
some night checks that equally if you go
to the corner then you have to calculate
what happens for example after knight
takes pawn because now there's no time
to go for the checkmating idea that i
pointed out because white has a sneaky
checkmate idea himself a checkmate
threat of knight takes pawn for example
the queen comes out knight takes pawn is
actually check it's not just a fork it's
checkmate as well so uh yeah devon anton
just calculating he's trying to give
prague a really difficult decision and
uh ivanka if you had to choose if you
had 30 seconds which way i would put my
key at the edge of the board
yeah i would go in the corner i would i
would allow the capture because one
thing that um i'm a little bit afraid of
for for white is that is if you just
take everything off and give up your
work
maybe even give up the rook
and the idea is after rook takes rook
trap the bishop
and now you could push the pawn forward
and cage this piece and okay he hasn't
gone this way this way looked very
tempting to me as well i think
instinct-wise i would have done that but
obviously we can't rely purely on
instinct we have to calculate as well
and prac has decided it's safer in the
center at least now the king guards this
pawn which as we showed is loose in some
variations uh so now again knight takes
pawn is very very well met by taking and
now threatening this nasty checkmate the
queen comes out but also keeping an eye
on the white knight i think this would
win a piece and big question for david
anton is how is he to get his bishop out
how is he going to extract it because
it's almost trapped if the black pawn
steps forward there's no escape also
some threats against this pawn some
threats of black pushing in the center
looks like it's going in prague's favor
unless david anton comes up with
something special now all right and in
our fundraiser for unicef we are getting
closer to 70 000. it's fantastic you
guys and
keep donating on chess24.com
donate and the auction for
a unique and exclusive
chess lesson with grandmaster david
howell only
26 minutes left now to make your bid the
current bid
726 dollars which is amazing but this is
a once in a lifetime opportunity to
improve your chess with david and ask
him about all his secrets and anything
you might wonder yeah i don't really
give lessons nowadays so this is a bit
of a break yeah and uh yeah an
opportunity so hopefully it will be fun
and instructive for anyone who chooses
to bid yeah and uh meanwhile white's
bishop coming back in the evaluation bar
slightly over to left uh to the
to prague side now
and uh that looks like a natural move to
me the bishop keeps an eye on both sides
of the board but there is still a
possibility that that bishop will get
hit at some point by a black pawn
it's tempting isn't it it's tempting
just to
prepare the hits at least
or
if i were feeling not so courageous i
would just uh develop my queen
just put her onto a good square start
eyeing up the white king yeah the black
queen it can't come a threat and
checkmate anymore because the white
knight is still on the f3 square so yeah
i guess you want to bring it to f6
ivanka line it up
on this f file looks very very tempting
i mean inching closer to the white king
is always a good idea with the queen now
especially when the black knight sits so
nicely in white's half
you could make an argument for maybe
pushing a pawn or improving the black
light squared bishop but
yeah i think
queen out by far the most natural
and uh prague we saw him in the last
game winning that kind of uh
that masterpiece that work of art uh we
saw him going for the opponent's king
one track mind but using all sides of
the board all angles
wait one second he's taking risks
do you like that on your banker is there
something wrong with it i i have no idea
it just wasn't on my radar whatsoever uh
gosh
because now there is an opportunity if
black wants to be greedy to go grabbing
material i guess that's his plan is that
his plan or does he want to just
maintain this pawn as a wedge just kind
of uh that thorn in white side that we
mentioned
okay we have got to jump in because
there was a huge reaction from you
ivanka it was on my radar but you know
me and my commitment issues i didn't
really want to touch this pawn because
it looks so good protected by its fellow
pawn in the center but prague went for
it he's not worried and uh now the white
queen had to move this pawn protected
sufficiently twice
so the queen had to dodge and now one
idea could be a knight check hitting the
king hitting the rook this is a fork and
i guess this would lead to a capture and
a sacrifice by white and now a quick
count shows that white is actually down
a rook for just a knight and pawn but
this is still unclear because white's
pawns are so strong on this left side
and i'm not so sure i want to go for
this with black maybe it's good maybe
it's not but uh more importantly this
knight is just so strong this pawn is so
strong maybe they're worth more than a
rook so prague if he just wants to be
greedy he'll jump in but if he wants
more maybe he could for example bring
his bishop out he could think about
starting to push this pawn forward
dislodging the white bishop
so many options for him yeah i love the
idea of dislodging the bishop actually i
mean i i don't think i would
i i don't think i would grab the rook
like
as you indicated i just think it's just
too dangerous too double edged like this
so the quality from your position if you
get greedy and give up your black knight
yeah
this way you can establish a new chain
right yeah this bishop is actually
trapped apart from one square it has to
move forward attacking the black rook
but maybe prague can just be
really kind of go for the aesthetic go
for the beauty prize and push his pawn
forward and uh yeah pawn chains this one
is definitely stronger than white's uh
selection over here now and uh yes you
give up some material okay he has gone
for the materialistic option but i was
going to say yes you give up the black
rook but here you can take the knight or
you can even maybe take the queen take
with the queen and try to slide over to
deliver a nasty attack again but okay
prague didn't go for this kind of flashy
continuation maybe there was a flaw to
it instead he chooses the simple
approach he takes the rook and now he is
ahead remember a rook for white's pawn
and knight so still an advantage
materially for prague but a long way to
go to convert it okay
you told me do not get too excited with
the bar in this game it will probably
swing it will swing a lot still i'm
pretty sure all right well uh richard
report is currently playing against liam
lair which reward is
before this round outside top eight but
um tai informs me that uh
with a win richard report is ready for
the quarter finals he needs to win this
game but he will be ready for court
finals no matter what happens in this
game
yeah just looking over the richer report
game it's
so hard to evaluate yeah
the evaluation bar is in the middle but
that means nothing it's still
super sharp and report has he has
winning chances he has winning chances
but
it's not going to be easy now we look at
the bar in the game between vedic and
magnus it's over duvet side oh okay i've
got to take a peek over just to update
you guys
and uh okay this one still very tense
fiddler has and no he doesn't have an
extra pawn it's yeah just in the balance
i think okay yes and the bar did go back
yeah
so uh okay so much drama intense round
keep everyone updated as the results
come in as the blunders happen
and uh okay meanwhile while prague going
aggressive with his pawns we mentioned
this was available earlier this option
but
now it feels a bit looser now the black
knight's gone the black king is
a bit airy
that one instinct-wise i'm not not so
keen on it but maybe concretely it works
maybe there's just no immediate flaw
because i think prague has the same idea
once that bishop moves the black pawn is
going to advance the black e pawn and
he's just going to try and steamroller
david anton in the center yeah it is a
very very very concrete thinking as you
say because you know the bishop moves
then
the black rook can move forward
and
black has it in his pocket to actually
push this pawn in the center whenever
and uh
white can't even get very fancy you know
by attacking the queen because then that
just improves the placing of the queen
she goes to where she wants to be so i
show this ivanka because there's a few
moves there
we're expecting the white bishop to move
and why not gain a bit of time while you
move attacking the black rook and you
mentioned moving the black rook and then
if white attacks the black queen the
queen improves right it just steps out
and still some issues with this bishop
but at least here white would be able to
maybe step to a central square i think
prague's idea is maybe similar to what
we showed a few moves ago give it up
maybe just give up this rook and uh just
push a pawn forward and the thing is
there's no real time to go and capture
this black rook because you don't flick
in this you actually play what we call
as vishwanzuk an in between move uh and
you capture the white knight instead
attacking the white queen and only next
move once white deals with this
uh this threat for example taking with
the pawn now you capture the white
bishop and quick count shows a bishop
for two pawns is still actually quite
unclear but i i would prefer the pieces
here i think black's bishops are going
to become strong later
so prague
i think he might even pre-move no matter
where the bishop goes he wants to push
this pawn and okay we have this position
is he okay he goes for your option yeah
but i don't like it now you know once i
saw it physically this is a funny thing
you know once i see it physically on a
board i'm like that doesn't quite appeal
to me but whereas you see it in your
head you're like okay that's that's a
move but he played that very very
quickly and your move was so much better
i mean it's tempting at least
maybe he was just worried about the
clock situation he wanted to be
practical no more risk taking he's got
extra material so he's done
kind of half the hard work
but now at least as mentioned the bishop
can escape he doesn't really want to go
back this way looks a bit wrong
so why not just slide across with the
rook and uh just drop the bishop back
and
i still probably would prefer black but
at least white now has a really strong
bishop and potential with these pawns
later on
okay and there we go as expected the
rook hits the black queen and the queen
is definitely going to dodge i think to
this square yep and uh yeah here we go
the white bishop could be protected
maybe or it could just drop back
still really
despite the material imbalance here
despite still some crazy stuff happening
is still anyone's game
yeah no definitely uh still crazy
because of this uh pawn structure and uh
white still we have to remind everyone
still has uh those two past pawns
okay and uh oh sorry i've just changed
game you see my analysis board that i
was just checking in on richard report
this is their position black's actually
doing very well because of these pawns
but let's go back to the game we're
looking at and let's go back to the
players
this is intense two minutes left on the
clock for pragnanda and just under three
minutes now for
david anton i'm just so curious if these
two are paying attention to the other
games and results all games lasting very
longer except from duda ding that was a
quick draw to secure
both of their spots they don't have time
yeah they only have two and a half
minutes
they should not be wasting that time
looking at what other people are doing
they need to be focused on this
incredibly sharp position
super focused yeah
and also it looks quite tense just from
their body language both of them seem to
be a little bit nervous
twiddling their hair
yeah actually i noticed when i a few
months ago at the grand swiss when i
played prague um just before mu 40 i
mean it was really complicated game it
wasn't clear who was better but just
before mu 40 you started twiddling with
his hand i realized actually maybe i was
doing quite well um so maybe that's a
sign of nerves
just a nervous tic playing with the hair
and uh okay meanwhile a couple of moves
black bringing his bishop and white's
queen sliding across
kind of keeping an eye on the center
from the diagonal but also maybe
supporting the advance of her pawns it
feels a bit superficial though the queen
on this square
i just clicked into this so on
chess24.com
you can check out many streams there's
streams in many different languages and
i just figured i want to check out the
spanish stream where peppa cuenca who
always gets so excited is commentating
on this game of course following their
spanish hope david danton i bet they are
feeling nervous now if he's going to
qualify
[Laughter]
shout out to our spanish speaking
friends definitely
and uh okay
yeah for the spaniards there is a threat
to deal with this white rook at the
bottom of the board is attacked by
black's bishop
and uh okay of course david anton spots
it just lifts his rook up one square
and uh now it might be time for this
black rook at the top of the board on
the left side to just slide across
still i mean yes the evaluation bar
likes black i think that's just to do
with black's material advantage the rook
versus knight important is a one point
advantage and that's reflected in the
bar but yeah still very hard to push
this one further for prague
anything he does involves pros and cons
drawbacks definitely yeah but uh your
move yeah just moving the rook towards
the open line getting ready to challenge
the bishop makes perfect sense and it's
no risk but this move is a bit
mysterious okay i shows he's really
worried about white's pawns but it
didn't look like they were going
anywhere immediately at least
and uh okay the evaluation fire reacts
he's slowing down the advance of white's
pawns but his black pawn now may be more
of a weakness than it previously was so
as we mentioned
some advantages to that move some real
drawbacks um for example that pawn is on
a light square could get targeted by
white's bishop later on also it costs a
really valuable move you could use that
move to improve a piece to push your own
pawns
and uh using can white use that extra
move for us for instance i was going to
suggest pushing harry
yeah when in doubt that's the that is
that is the rule right um
okay
but uh david anton just moves his queen
i definitely feel that the nerves the
time trouble nerves are already coming
because
confidential i'm sorry uh he just
improved the white queen but is it even
an improvement he just it feels like he
just wanted to pass the move back to
pregnant he didn't want to commit
anything
i think he's struggling for a plan with
white
and okay black does come across as we
advocated on the last turn very sensible
putting some serious pressure actually
on white's bishop in the middle of the
board which is white's pride and joy
white's best piece but only defended
once not defended by a pawn so not quite
anchored on any outpost
and uh also black has ideas at some
point of sliding the other rook across
doubling up the two rooks on on the d
file
two rooks are better than one and uh
that is actually a bit of a threat that
is a huge threat and
how how is white going to deal with that
because ideally white would like to
i was going to say magically put a pawn
on the h5 square and then try to keep it
now he only pushes harry one square
forward you wanted it two squares i
wanted two squares because i'm i'm not
very subtle you know i wanted to push
the pawn one square all the way up to h5
and then wouldn't that also be sensible
because then it would be protected by
the other pawn it would be protected one
i think he's just at a loss for move to
play i mean i don't think anything is
really appealing to him and the clock is
ticking down and i think now is the
moment for pregnant ander after david
anton's played some really kind of
hesitant moves just to slide the rook
across on the e5 double up the two rooks
against black against the white bishop
and i think that's going to cause some
real headaches for david anton i think
white's going to have to allow a rook
trade he's going to have to move his
bishop out the way but a trade of one
set of rooks is going to help black
remember when you have a selection of
pieces when there's an imbalance you
want one of everything it's like ice
cream flavors you want one of everything
and once you remove white's rook off the
board white loses a lot of control over
the lines white only plays with knights
and those can be
kept an eye on so
i think this is an opportunity for
prague he doesn't necessarily need to
rush with this idea but
he's got to move quickly okay he goes on
the attack with his pawns
i didn't expect that one um
it is it is committable because if it
goes wrong it's going to go seriously
wrong now black's position on this side
feels a bit loose that was not necessary
i think you should have rushed to trade
things off while you had the opportunity
and uh okay
his idea was to create a square for the
black king he didn't feel comfortable
with his king at the top of the board
understandably so now the black king
also protecting the black queen so
wait david is there not some g4 ideas
yeah uh definitely in the air for black
king in range of the white knights okay
this hasn't happened
um actually yeah maybe you're right
ivanka maybe that was a serious
opportunity for david anton but now
after a trade maybe still an opportunity
because there's still a night jump
there's a huge threat in the position
white's knight wants to go to the middle
of the board to the d5 square it will
hit the black queen it will hit the
black rook and even the black bishop
that's a big threat it has to be dealt
with and prague does he controls this
central square with his bishop
yeah i think he loosened his king too
much he should have pushed the black
pawn just one square just to control
everything
uh he wants to be aggressive but that
aggression might backfire and look at
this a big big threat again now for
white white wants to capture the f5 pawn
his bishop lining up against it there's
no way to defend it david yeah look at
prague suddenly leaning back it's
turning it's turned it was all to do
with loosening his king's position
loosening those pawns
and he's had to give a pawn back
another pawn and now white will just
capture this guy with a knight that's a
check on the f5 square knights on f5
will thrive white has great pieces as
well
oh
i think he just delayed the right this
rook move was the right idea
five moves ago he just right idea wrong
timing
he just got way over
over ambitious he needed to play a
little bit more classically and i think
his nerves yeah he wanted to force
things and he's lost a pawn but look at
how look at those three minor pieces
that david anton has you know they're
just running riot all over those light
squares yeah the knights they can't be
kicked away from their posts right now
um especially the white knight in the
middle in front of that pawn that white
knight is rock solid and uh pregnant are
just throwing pawns forward giving up
pawns he wants to open up his bishops
i'm not so sure about that i would have
run away with the black king again it
feels too close to the white knights
right now it's within checking distance
and uh okay what would david do will he
just retreat the white bishop will he
capture this black pawn in the center he
has to be a little bit careful with how
he captures that horn i mean he can't
capture with a bishop because black
might get a
crafty and a capture on knight or does
it work
that's a lot of calculation it's a lot
of calculation okay but um yeah david
antoine okay he decides to take the
safety first option dropping back his
bishop so reinstating this threat of the
white knight going to that magical f5
square that we talk about so much
that would be a devastating fork check
and hitting the black rook in the middle
but this is the thing the evaluation bar
we predicted it right from the opening
uh it's just a crazy position and it has
been for the whole game and it will
continue to swing it's just that
and he has 10 seconds under 10 seconds
okay and he takes your advice and he
puts his king in the corner on a dark
square this is great especially when low
on time you want your king as far away
from your opponent's nights as possible
i wouldn't have gone to the corner i
would have gone the other way but
at least he doesn't have to worry about
checks but a new threat has emerged and
that is he's retreated the bishop to
attack the pawn how are you going to
defend that pawn eight seconds left
and david anton is actually very fast i
played him at blitz a few times he's
very quick
prague of course good too but
yeah with this time of disadvantage 18
against 50 seconds it could come into
play at least black has ideas now of
bringing the black queen all the way
into the bottom left corner and checking
the white king on the first rank can
white get greedy and grab that pawn on
a6 i think david anton wishes he had
more time to work that out and it's very
brave for to bring the white bishop away
offside to go and capture a pawn but
if it's possible it's probably just a
very good move
okay oh now clock's balancing out okay
safety safety first from uh david anton
so maybe now he's threatening knight
takes pawn in the center yeah possibly
yep that black central pawn weak now
look at this pragnanda no fear when in
doubt push harry the h-boy yeah and he's
actually got a specific idea he wants to
push that pawn even further and open up
the dark square diagonal for his bishop
but it does come at the cost of a pawn
as ivanka mentioned this pawn was
hanging
and uh okay just has to centralize the
queen it doesn't really matter e5 or d4
it's k it's moved to e5
this white knight in the center might be
protected by a bishop
and david navarro three points for him
that's taking him to uh 21 points
same as the two these two guys um so
with a loss here for either of these two
they're not safe
okay ty mentioned navara has a better
tiebreak maybe than these two so
very very important game he's going to
be watching this game
now david navarro and pragananda six
making that move with six minutes six
minutes six seconds to spare he wishes
it was six minutes and now oh queen
trade offered
is this going to benefit white white has
a lot of pawns white has a knight and
three pawns for black's rook so white's
actually ahead of material can the black
rook gobble up the white pawns
especially on that left side before it's
too late
pregnant he's in trouble he's in huge
trouble i mean it's all just gone
terribly wrong for him
the problem is is that if he tries to
get greedy and grab some pawns on the
left you know the white knight is
ideally placed to defend those pawns and
there we go
pawn hunting david anton he's going for
black's remaining lone her soldier on
this left side and uh okay prank doing
the same trying to use his rook to
attack
but you can step this pawn forward you
can jump forward with the knight
lots and lots of options
and two connected pass pawns now for
white this is looking almost
almost like a white wind those two pawns
super strong okay um would you grab the
what would you do here as black would
you go bishop takes pawn and just
yeah hope for the best black can go and
take this white pawn on the g3 square
because actually if white recaptures the
black rook can take the white knight in
the middle but
oh i don't know i feel like those two
white pawns on the left are just gonna
fly forward if the black bishop
disappears
so i think it's a good idea practical
terms uh centralizing the black king if
the black king can pick itself up and
put itself near those white pawns then
maybe you get to safety but that black
king's still a mile away
and uh okay pragnando rocking back and
forth he knows he needs some magic now
he needs a miracle to save this game
because white's pawns are so close those
white pawns will cost black a bishop
most likely maybe even more yeah and
here comes charlie and uh all charlie
needs is the assistance of some pieces
to move forward
yeah
okay the white king comes in i didn't
expect that one i thought the bishop
would maneuver itself round but no okay
i like this yeah
fortunately for black white just
controls all of the light squares and
you only you can only find the dark
squares but there's nothing on those uh
on that color complex so okay the black
king comes across and your idea now
ivanka look at this bishop it cuts off
the black king's
kind of root towards the white pawns and
it's going to take a step back defend
the remaining pawns and just kind of
those two pawns together going to hold
each other's hand and walk down the
board okay sneaky there from prague
attacking the white knight but
this move defending the knight attacking
the black bishop multi-purpose
david anton it's
i know the evaluation bar is not 100
sure whether it's winning but it does
look that way the momentum is all on
white side
wow and now with navara's win 21 points
richer reports has played a draw 21
points
then a draw 22 points
i mean would probably secure the place
yeah for these two and now it's not
looking too good for pregnant
no and david anton there's no reason for
him to take a draw because he's got no
risk here um even if white loses those
two points on the left it's probably
still fine it's probably still a draw
white tonight it's just too strong
so david anton playing risk-free chess
going for the win
and uh prague here he is the one on the
back foot but okay he's looking away
does he think he's saving this now next
move no matter where the white king goes
black is going to go back where he came
from attacking the white knight and
attacking the pawn next to it
so
pregnant a good fighter he's definitely
a good fighter i mean thus he's shown
that throughout the tour he's got a lot
of grit and resilience
and even in these kind of quite hopeless
positions he's still finding
opportunities to fight
and uh
i think just some calculation needs to
be done here but would you step forward
with the king or would you just i think
step back step back yeah yeah and now
once the black rook retreats attacking
the white knight there's literally
nothing else black can do because the
white pawns are advancing cat the big
question is can white advance the b pawn
right now to try and make a new queen
uh just give up the white knight but
just bank everything on these two white
pawns and he doesn't do this he's
repeating the position okay surprising
so black can give another check here and
that's the second time we'll have seen
that position he has seen the other
results maybe he's just playing safe now
david anton
he did take a while there i'm not sure
whether he looked over the other games
or the other results but there's no need
there's no need okay he plays for the
win though okay he's going for the win
he's not taking the draw going forward
but the black rook can again start
attacking this white knight
and it's it's not so easy to win anymore
um the black king wants it moose
suddenly the black rook has got an eye
on both of white's pawns and you can't
save them both
okay i mean it feels like white should
be winning still because there's just so
many pawns white pieces all so active
well coordinated
maybe he's just gonna switch attack you
know
after the king moves he's gonna go well
actually i'm gonna grab your pawn
and say yes you know you want those two
pawns on the left but you know like a
hydra a new head emerges okay a bit of
an odd choice of square there from uh
pregnant going to a light square it
doesn't quite make sense does it but if
i were him i would just play it easy
king takes king take the pawn
i must say i was uh at the world blitz
championship in poland and david anton
failed to win a position where he had
three extra pawns on one side of the
board against andy shkiri so he's got
nervous in this type of position before
but okay wow he's going all out on the
advance with this king the black king
using itself as a blockader for white
spawns now interesting prague finding
resources
okay so
it might be time for your idea ivanka
just grab all of black's remaining pawns
get those off the board remove any
remaining risk yeah
okay 25 seconds to make a decision yeah
i remember the game it was when he
was three pawns up right and he got
checkmated or was uh oh that was someone
else
but yeah either way uh he failed to win
okay well he's been grabbing some pawns
with the king this is good stuff okay so
if he continues grabbing pawns with the
white king he'll have four there we go
white has four pawns against black zero
but black has the rook versus knight
advantage so
can pragnanda hold he needs a miracle
still he needs to somehow eliminate all
of white's remaining pawns
and according to tai if
anton wins and also beat it look at the
bar and lead its game against magnus
crossing if they win prague will be out
unfortunately okay he'd say draw
yeah fit it looks like he is winning
against magnus still some hard work to
be done though in that one so
um
yeah i mean i was going to say he's is
hoping that prague can help him out or
is it the other way around but it looks
like they're in a direct check out this
ending so there's a possibility now that
black can actually play bishop takes no
it's not possible yeah i was gonna
certainly not not possible bishop takes
porn because of knight takes bishop but
okay the bishop can step back
yeah give a check okay
pragnanda moves his king towards the
action
no good way for the black bishop to run
and kind of open up a discovered attack
against white's bishop so it makes some
sense to put your king in front of
white's pawns there might be stalemate
ideas or the king might act as a
blockader while the rest of the pieces
harass
white okay look at those three pawns
though those three foot soldiers
i mean those were two scary pawns on the
left side a few minutes ago now white
has replaced them with three scary
connected pawns
okay and i'm expecting
the corner porn harry to move forward
okay
in practical terms you nearly never save
a position like this
there's just no way um you need to
somehow give up your bishop for all of
white's remaining pawns
that's not going to happen only one or
two of the pawns will sit on dark
squares but the bar in the v did carlsen
game just i think actually went over
slightly to magnus's side well at least
in the middle uh it's actually a dead
draw now magnus found a way to trick
vidit and he's actually removing vidic's
final pawn it's going to come down to
king and knight versus king which is a
draw no checkmating material left
that means beat it is out and that means
pregnant chances are growing again okay
oh
wow
he won't know this but he's still
fighting like a lion in this game to
save uh save things and try to increase
his chances
okay this white pawn advancing
i was going to say as well the other
scenario is
if white's pawns all disappear at the
cost of black's rook and bishop
the position if it's just king versus a
king bishop and knight that is a win
that is a checkmate
and uh i think david anton will know how
to win that one yeah it's not easy
actually lots of top ground masters have
failed to win that but
it's a theoretical end game and okay a
knight check
if this knight is removed yes black can
win a pawn in the process but white's
king will be too active white's g pawn
will run forward and that's just game
over prague needs to keep his pieces on
the board
actually he's got some he's got the
outline of a stalemate at least
so he needs to somehow if this position
black could give up his rook and give up
his bishop
it's stalemate but the problem is giving
up a bishop is the hardest thing in
chess your opponent doesn't necessarily
need to take it
and
okay
he's found a trick so there's a very
nice idea we've got to show it right we
have to show this because uh right now
prague is relying on one trick to save
the game and that is stalemate his king
cannot move in the corner and it cannot
be checked okay
david anton dodging the trick if he
pushed his pawn forward we would have
said bishop takes pawn sacrificing the
bishop and once the king takes it
rotates bishop sacrificing the rook as
well and look at this
this is stalemate it's not czech and
black cannot move anything so this is a
recurring theme that will arise the rest
of the game and
unfortunately the king is in the corner
we've got to go back yeah we've got to
go back because white brought the knight
back and uh okay checkmate is threatened
now
it's just game over unfortunately i
think for prague look he leans back the
white knight can jump in at some point
there's no rush actually with that move
and the black king trapped
and uh
still one last trick in the position
after white recaptures black can take
this white pawn
and again capturing this bishop is
stalemate but white will not take the
bait
it's not going to be a draw because this
pawn steps forward and now black's
bishop can't sacrifice itself in the
right way if you take this pawn now
white's king steps back giving black's
king some breathing space no stalemate
and two connected passports are a win in
this position and ty's telling me that's
going to mean david anton is true
navarra is through pregnant will be out
with that loss
okay and unfortunately no hope white
simply has
one plan in mind and it's unstoppable
the bishop will move out the way the
white king will move and white's pawns
will trap the black king
so close
so so close heartbreaking
really
turn of events as well
uh he was actually bossing this game for
a large chunk of it pragnando he just
weakened his king at the wrong moment
and look at this white's pawn is simply
going to step forward two squares and
that's going to be checkmate
and uh also david anton that's really
instructive he's given black's king one
scare one square uh to breathe uh so no
stalemates there's still one chance yeah
one chance if you take away
the h7 square from the king
well then the black bishop can sacrifice
itself yeah so
of course david antoine he's already
seen the stalemate threats of the
stalemate kind of motif we saw that
earlier and
now the white king's just gonna actually
i think maybe pushing both pawns would
have been a mistake there uh but the
king yep stepping across and plus 100
means checkmate is coming
no way to prevent it there's just one
trick left with white's g-pawn pushes
that can sacrifice the bishop so white's
bishop goes away
no more stalemates and pragmata
is he about to resign he i think he's
giving up and then his chances have gone
david anton really nice end game
technique we've got to give credit to
the spaniard
that's in a few seconds we will see a
result
this is almost a little bit
heartbreaking he was one win away from
qualifying to the knockout stage in the
air things masters
pragnanda
and now
now it's going to be basically down to
tie breaks knocking him out of this
tournament
after such an incredible performance and
look at that 100 on the bar and it's
over david anton makes it through to the
quarterfinals
it ends here